It's that the question of Mayotte,
contrary to appearances,
it's 1 question that makes COS in Switzerland
Within the French political class,
uh even the forces of the left that is 1 moment it was close to
the Comorian position on the island,
uh The island of Mayotte We end today with uh To rally uh To the official
speech by continuing to say that Mayotte is 1 French territory because Mayotte
is enshrined in the French constitution.
This is what we see today with the position uh Of a part uh Of the left,
uh Like the she is a girl uh France is submissive,
of course,
but also all the forces of the left which,
uh,
are today part of what is called the nupece and and that,
nobody can contest it.
There are only a few,
I say well,
a few parliamentarians weigh,
who by the way,
continues in uh to support the Comorian position,
uh uh of Uh end on Mayotte,
and this for ideological reasons.
If you look well,
if you follow well the interventions of these parliamentarians,
they are interventions that are much more uh,
uh Ideological,
which is worth in the sense,
uh It is to demolish to the fact la la la la la the position of France,
uh Compared to uh uh to his to his to his alignment on uh on uh.
On the American ideology,
the Pac americana more than anything else by the way uh But it is 1
speech Often that is devoid of depth.
In fact,
it's not the same motives as we are doing so the few supporters that today,
uh We see in line,
uhh Finally within the French political class,
uh coming from some parliamentarians,
uh Communists.
This is not something we can rely on.
But overall,
we can say that there is 1 consensus in the French political class
to say that today Mayotte is 1 French territory And it is because there
is 1 informed consent within the French political class that French
policy on the Mayotte question has never changed from New York since.
Uh That we've gained access since the Comoros gained independence
So we need to stop believing that,
uh We can lean on,
we can lean on uh?
On some supporters in France,
perhaps there will be some on the left,
on the right,
but for now,
we must accept.
Uh The reality and reality today is that the
French political class and on that,
uh Reign 1 consensus on the fact that mayo you are already registered
is already registered in the French constitution.
But they made the choice to base uh their positioning,
in any case uh their uh their hum,
their argumentation on the question of Mayotte on elements of French internal
rights While there we are uh Faced with 1 hmm to 1 problem that imposes
2 States and And That uh In in in in in in in 1 authentic case,
only international law should normally decide.
That's 1 1st point,
2nd point In this fight to recover our entire sovereignty,
uh On the whole national territory,
uh More precisely to Uh Get the return of the Comorian
island of Mayotte in its lap sea.
We had the support of some countries,
most countries at the international level,
I mean,
most countries in the concert of nations,
uh uh Great countries that have helped us a lot,
whether it's in Africa,
whether it's in Asia,
but also in Latin America.
These countries,
uh We did a lot of help in advancing our cause uh uh Within United Nations bodies
And Uh And all this thanks to the,
the efforts made by uh uh Some authorities at the time,
uh More specifically uh Some presidents at the time,
but also some foreign ministers and some diplomats who worked.
Uh uh,
day and night so we can have the le.
The 1 unwavering support from De of different nations uh uh uh Of the world.
But unfortunately,
this support has diminished in recent years.
Uh We see 1 little what happens today with countries of the region for,
to name but a few,
1 country like Tanzania 1 country like uh Like Madagascar,
which and so far have always been uh Of unwavering
support for uh for uh On the question,
finally,
1 unwavering support of the Comorian state on the question of Mayotte.
Today,
we see that their position uh uh,
is getting closer.
1 little bit of course,
little by little,
but uh,
we see very well that uh uh of of the intractables that they were with
France on the question of the jersey,
they begin today,
for reasons of de de de of real politics,
to get closer.
Uh Of the approach to France If we take the example uh uh Of the 2 countries,
for example 2 countries of the region Madagascar and Madagascar.
Uh,
we know very well that from the beginning,
it is 1 of the great supporters of the Comoros.
Uh On the Mayotte file,
they never agreed uh To deal with France on this issue They had 1.
1 position?
Uh Intractable uh with uh With the French on the question of Mayotte,
they never wanted to concede in Dans quoi,
dans quoi quoi sur ce,
sur questo dossier de Mayotte.
But when you look 1 little over the last few years,
uh Uh how Madagascar could,
uh In its relations we consider with France,
could make concessions but also uh look at each other 1 little what the dancers
did with uh with the French on the The the uh uh the The relationship finally
on the Yeah on relations in air services on We see well,
uh That these country there,
uh uh uh uh slowly but surely are tipping and uh to uh to uh uh to 1 other,
1 other finally 1 other position which will be much closer,
the French position and and and and and And unfortunately we can't,
we can't,
we can't not see it because we see it every day through published articles
But agreements signed on the left to the right between these 2 countries and
the and the and France which actually concerns jersey it can only worry us.
And and and and The position of the current Comorian authorities
on the issue of Western Sahara and And has not been done to facilitate things,
it has not been done At least for uh for uh.
Finally for countries like South Africa and Algeria that have
that have uh uh um Firm imposition,
uh These are countries that have 1 valuable diplomacy,
uh That are not opportunistic diplomacy like most countries in the region.
Unfortunately you see that if the Comorians decided to support
the Moroccans on the issue of Western Sarah,
while until then we have always observed 1 form of on the issue.
All this is not done so that,
so that we can have the support,
so that we can continue to obtain the support of some of these great countries,
1 country like Algeria,
1 country like South Africa and others.
By the way,
I would like to draw the tension uh From the public on 1 point.
Lately,
there has been talk of Russian support for the commord on the Mayotte issue.
I would like to land the question uh,
of everyone on this so-called support which in truth is not at all.
1 support is look closely how the?
The Russian authorities mention the question of Mayotte.
They put 1 kind of parallelism between,
uh,
1 kind of parallel between the shirt situation of the Crimean situation.
In fact,
they are putting forward the question of shirts precisely to challenge the French
diplomacy which is criticizing them on what
is happening in Crimea But in truth,
what do they say the Russians,
the Russians,
they say that we do not understand you French,
because what we are doing,
what we have done 1 crimé,
what we have done in the dombase,
that's exactly what you did in Mayotte with the commords.
..
And we can't draw from his reasoning.
1 any support from Russia To the comment on the Mayotte question,
on the contrary.